hey Mary my check on Mike three I need a
mic check Mary can you do news today
jess is out we need someone to do news
no I don't have time today ask Rob
you're in Astra food Irie fed you would
rob hours go hey rob jess is out we need
someone to news yeah what can do it what
are you doing can't do i'm talking him
Joey news jean-luc news you've had the
best now here's the rest I'm Alex this
is GS news and here's your first story
we finally figured out what will happen
to xbox 360 and ps3 players of destiny
when the next expansion rise of iron
launches in September developer bungee
is not bringing rods of iron to last gen
consoles and instead it's slowly winding
down support for ps3 and xbox 360
players over the coming months if you're
still playing on the last gen system
don't worry too much just yet Bungie
will still support strikes raids prison
of elders weekly challenges and other
modes indefinitely but last gym players
are out of luck when it comes to new
content and live events because bungee
won't be bringing those two older
systems any longer this means no more
trials of osiris on ps3 and 360 so you
haven't gotten to the lighthouse just
yet you still got a few weeks to grab
that sweet loop before bungee stop
supporting it in august on the bright
side this also means that Bungie will be
able to add more bells and whistles to
the current gen versions of destiny so
hopefully rise of iron will be
especially cooled next steps we've got
news about everyone's favorite hero link
in a recent interview series creator
Shigeru Miyamoto put persistent rumors
to rest when he confirmed that mainline
Zelda games will never have a main
character other than link when asked by
game colt if we'll ever see a zelda game
with a female protagonist Miyamoto
explained we clearly talked with a team
to make a game centered about chic so I
cannot say it's impossible to see
something of the sort in the future but
in the classic games in the series link
is the hero and that will never change
he did hint that other spin-off Zelda
games might have different characters
though saying for the rest you have to
be patient and see what happens so maybe
one day we'll finally get that chic game
after
I've just checked and Mary's still too
busy to do GS news so you're stuck with
me for one more story more powerful
versions of xbox one and ps4 are on
their way and it looks like publishers
are pretty happy about it Electronic
Arts take two and Ubisoft three of the
biggest publishers in the business all
told games industry top is that the mid
generation console refreshes are
beneficial for both the companies and
the players Ubisoft's Alan core
explained the beautiful thing is it will
not split the communities and I think
it's important that when you've been
playing a game for a lot of years and
invested a lot of time that you can
carry on without having to start over
completely again so even though the ps4
neo and xbox one Scorpios sound like the
straight out of some 80s sci-fi movie it
looks like the new consoles are shaping
up to be nice additions to the industry
that's it for me your 5th string hosts
check back tomorrow for the triumphant
return of Mary or Rob
you